only on CBS this morning Facebook CEO
Mark Zuckerberg and his wife
philanthropist Priscilla Chan invited us
into their home well invited may be a
stretch how about I said please mr. mr.
Zuckerberg can we please come over and
they said okay
they have never allowed a TV camera crew
inside their home before today so we
were able to see firsthand who this
couple is outside of their first big
Facebook lives they discussed raising
their two young daughters and how family
inspires work that they do our extensive
conversations with this couple we think
show a different side of the Zuckerberg
both at home and at work
Priscilla how do you handle all of the
incoming that goes to Facebook that goes
to mark specifically I think it's it's
hard like the way your gut feels when
your best friend walks home comes home
and it's like hard day not sure what
needs to come next or you know waking up
at night and being like he's still not
in bed and so I see that I also see that
we're still so fortunate like the
touchstone of our family and our kids
and just knowing that we are we're okay
what can we actually bring to the table
it's that family that motivated them to
build the Chan Zuckerberg initiative and
now four year old company funding
achievements in medical science and
other fields I love that it's Chan
Zuckerberg not Zuckerberg a couple
launched it just days after the birth of
their first daughter so in order to
truly understand the origins of this
huge philanthropic endeavor you really
have to go back home to meet max the
little girl who unknowingly started at
all now joined by her little sister
August okay can you say hi to go who
recently had a birthday me how old did
you turn how do you raise children when
you can really give them anything
materially to be grounded well I think
first of all we we
give them everything so I think that's
an important piece but they also just
have responsibilities so you're saying
you teach them that they have chores
your kids have responsive
responsibilities we also take them to
work Marc and I take both of them to
work to the office to see sort of like
what we do how we contribute so how do
you not bring work home guys aren't you
you work together you live together well
I disagree with the premise of that
question we care deeply about our work
and so we don't leave it at the door but
we are super careful about thinking
about is this the moment to talk about
it I guess it was when you kept on
bringing up work on date night how often
is date night and what is day we're
pretty good about we do it every week
yeah and no work talk on date night no
work so I don't start a date night whose
idea was that
it's Marc's idea really yes Marc are you
the sentimental one in this relationship
I think that would be a surprising
conclusion to come to but that may be
where this interview is going another
surprise the couple's first date way
back at Harvard after meeting in line
for the bathroom at a frat party almost
didn't lead to a second date there was a
major red flag what I'm like a type A
student at the end of the date he said I
have a take home midterm I need to do
but I'd rather hang out with you which I
thought would be this like a compliments
going nowhere he's blowing off his
homework from your standpoint Marc
you're thinking that's a way to impress
her to say I'm so interested in you I'd
much rather spend time with you than my
aunt worked yeah and I was pretty
confident I could do the test Facebook
launch what did you think Priscilla your
life would be with this man not
different than before he launched the
website no one in their wildest dreams
would imagine that this is what would
happen after that it was just it was his
next project people say the success of
Facebook certainly has a lot to do with
Priscilla's influence on you would you
agree with that I think that's the
got to be true you run things by her you
we also just talk about our philosophy
on life and then that ends up you know
having a lot of effects on you know how
I think about building my team at
Facebook and the values with which we
run the organization and like your
marriage vows I there's a line in the
vows that you said about mark he makes
you a better version of yourself he
makes you a better version of yourself
how he just believes in me so much of
even when I don't believe in myself
highlighting where I have strengths
where I may not see my own strength what
does she do for you well I mean you have
this way of communicating kind of the
soul of something I think it's inspiring
and something that we would all do
better to you know be able to do more of
that every year you you pick a project I
remember one year you wanted to learn
Chinese you learn Chinese what did that
mean to you when he did that for Silla
maybe a little frustrated that my
Mandarin was better than yours for a
little bit your Mandarin was better than
mine briefly but I mean the thing the
real takeaway I had from that year is
that mark is better at talking than
listening and because I got to a point
in Mandarin where I could say a lot of
things that I wanted but my listening
was not good so I remember having this
conversation was like why do you think
my listening is and Mandarin is not as
good you're like it's not Mandarin so
what is it that would surprise people
about Mark Zuckerberg I think you're
getting it out of him today go he's kind
of a softy those two are so tight and so
connected and really each other's
biggest cheerleaders and people said
what are you guys doing in the kitchen
we're making challah bread and people
said well you know that was for the
camera no there's a recipe book that
says Max's or daughters
challah bread they make it every Friday
for Shabbat dinner and it clearly been
worn and used many many times they are
real people with real issues with real
problems in real gold you can see it
right there in camo you can mister you
know what I like I like when I asked
what does she do for you he didn't say
to me goes what you do is is that
very to her he turned to her no the the
two of them together is very endearing
and they are really quite a unit it was
nice to see great appreciation for them
letting us come to their home because
they do not do that yeah that's rare